protests are intensifying in Sacramento
after two police officers shot and
killed an unarmed black man firing 20
rounds of ammunition the officers
thought 22 year old Stephon Clarke had a
gun he did not hundreds of people shut
down a freeway and blocked entrances to
the golden one Center where the NBA team
the Sacramento Kings were getting ready
to play the game eventually started in
front of a much smaller crowd
anne-marie green is tracking the
protests we stand here before you old
young black white brown and we are all
united in our commitment the crowd
inside Sacramento's golden one Center
Arena last night was thin but the
message from Sacramento Kings owner
Vivek Ranadive was full of resolved
we're gonna work really hard to prevent
this kind of a tragedy from happening
again Ranadive was compelled to speak by
hundreds of protesters who were blocking
thousands of ticket holders from getting
inside the arena the outrage is over the
death of 22 year old father of two and
Sacramento resident Stephon Clark Clark
was killed last Sunday when officers who
were pursuing him on foot for suspected
vandalism mistook his cell phone for a
gun and began shooting at him they
unloaded at least 20 rounds from their
weapons but they later learned Clark was
unarmed earlier yesterday Sacramento's
black lives matter group called on
supporters to take their outrage to the
streets they ended at the golden one
Center arena where their motive was
clear
we're just whop dude we're making
everybody uncomfortable being black and
Camino in America is uncomfortable for
today we're going to make people feel
how we feel uncomfortable